bienvenue à tous c'est l'épisode 9 de la
saison 4 d'envergure ce soir on
s'intéresse un joueur de la grosse 12
l'habituel jared butler un joueur de
troisième année universitaire qui
commence à faire de l'oeil aux carottes
par son adresse à trois points par son
angel par sa qualité offensive
et donc on va en parler avec manu avec
plus qu un petit nouveau et avec nico
c'est parti c'est l'épisode 9 de la
saison 4 berne et on y va
nico manu bonsoir soit j'en dis
bienvenue à hugues bienvenus
ce soir hugues notre dernier arrivé dans
l'équipe qui s'occupe donc de cette
conférence big toile alors évidemment on
regarde d'autres d'autres rencontres
mais voilà on se sépare un petit peu le
travail et donc huguet et là pour être
le spécialiste territoriale donc la
victoire qui est une des conférences
majeures de n 6 de voler ou jouent donc
jarrett butler notre sujet du soir et
nico je vais te demander avec ton sens
de la formule habituelle de me dresser
un petit portrait robot rapide de qui
quel joueur est jarrett butler alors
j'arrête butler pour moi c'est le score
comme on aime le meneur arrière donc
deux nés en 2001 on aime aussi les
joueurs qui effectivement mûrissent
comme ça en une pièce a fait du bien sa
troisième année
et donc voilà si je veux si je dois en
une phrase on va dire c'est le micro
wave score comme comme les américains
aiment appeler ce type de joueur donc le
joueur scoreur micro ondes
en français c'est moins sexy forcément
sexy le prototype que tout l'incitent à
chaque fois qu'on donne l'exemple du
mike powell scoreur c'est lou williams
sortie dans ses multiples sixième homme
de l'année en nba évidemment d'arette
butler népal williams williams n'est pas
john butler manu quels sont les gros
points forts de jared butler sur quoi il
va capitaliser pour avoir un avenir en
professionnel son shoot déjà wii est
très bon au shoot notamment à trois
points où notre option en plus sur ses
trois saisons il a augmenté à 6 à 5
de façon intéressante qui est passé de
35 à 45 sur ses trois saisons
donc c'est vachement intéressant donc
c'est vraiment ça qui qui va faire sa
force en plus d'une défense assez solide
mais ça on y reviendra
un peu plus tard très bien donc un gros
shooteur effectivement je donne ses
mensurations un mètre 91 vous pouvez les
retrouver sur notre site envergure
penser au 1 mètre 91 1 93 d'envergure
c'est pas énorme
86 kg il fait peut-être un peu plus
depuis qu'on a rentré ses chips j'en
sais rien il paraît en tout cas assez
dense comme joueur est donc troisième
année nico tu l'as dit néant née en 2000
mais il n'est pas vieux par rapport à sa
classe son expérience on va dire il va
faire un cursus classique aux états unis
donc les chiffres à trois points sont
45% sucre sur presque six tentatives par
match aux lancers francs c'est un peu
moins bien cette saison mais en carrière
au total c'est quand même 77 5%
donc c'est un un shooter une valeur sûre
on va dire au niveau du du tir
cette saison hugues dans quel dans quel
contexte ils évolué puisque baylor c'est
clairement un des favoris au final fort
si le tournoi de la march madness a lieu
évidemment c'est une des meilleures
équipes du pays
bah oui comme tu le dises un contexte
idéal pour dire être butler qui est dans
l'une des peut-être de meilleure attaque
du pays avec bellor ça se joue à gonzaga
et puis des plus grosses défenses
haussier du pays il est dans un contexte
où il a à côté de lui deux autres
porteurs de balle donc pour le coup il
peut partager son ballon il a il ya
beaucoup d'options
et puis la d intérieur qui sont très
très bons pour poser des écrans pour
orienter le jeu et est une compétition
assez athlétique
donc effectivement contexte presque
parfait peut-être trop parfait pour
digérer butler justement trop parfait
parce que tu penses que ça dévalue un
petit peu là ça son apport c'est à dire
qu'ils pourraient ils y seraient moins
mises en lumière dans une équipe plus
faible
oui pourrait soit plus ce statut ou bien
justement nous verrons peut-être un peu
plus ses points faibles
par exemple il joue à côté d'un certain
john mitchell qui est aussi dans
quelques mots qu'un qui porte beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup le ballon qui dribble
énormément
le tank attaque se met en place et puis
lui ensuite s'ils récupèrent le ballon
soit parce qu'il a un catch and shoot il
est très efficace soit parce que
l'action est le permet et du coup il
enchaîne sur un pick and roll et en
dribles il passe donc voilà c'est pas le
porteur de balle principal de son équipe
même si pour moi c'est le meilleur
bollène lors de son équipe à quoi ça
ressemble au niveau des responsabilités
dans les dernières minutes c'est quelque
chose d'assez intéressant est ce que
c'est lui qui prend les gros tir tout le
temps ou en tout cas qui crée le gros
tir ou ou pas forcément à style souvent
quand même ça lui revient
ça lui revient alors il ya des
exceptions quand un des joueurs est très
très chaud parce que ça partage bien le
ballon et qu'ils ont un côté assez
exceptionnel quand même mais on a vu par
exemple contre oklahoma state avec un
match assez serré
au départ finalement il n'est pas dedans
du tout et puis il faut faire un écart
ses dires et de l'autre lors qui prend
les ballons qui va prendre des tirs
parfois avec deux défenseurs sur lui
qu'il aimait et qui crée le décalage
donc ouais c'est le leader de cette
équipe
nico est ce que j'arrête butler peut
avoir des possibilités de création parle
justement de la création dans les
dernières minutes
hughes a parlé d'un bon haendel chez
plutôt d'accord qu'est ce que tu en
penses toi
nicolas tu as muse
j'imagine à pardon de burlats là je suis
en monologue je tiens à rassurer tout le
monde ce ne sont pas les monologues du
vagin à une fois ceci étant dit je
voudrais revenir désolé sur sur ce qu il
disait par rapport au fait d'avoir la
balle dans les mains dans les dernières
secondes
dans ce magnifique outil qui est cette
synergie
on a justement son pourcentage de deux
tirs clutch si tu veux sur les
possessions il reste moins de 4 secondes
pour l'instant jack badler n'est pas
clutch voilà donc c'est je crois me
souvenir qu'il doit être à moins de la
deux paniers sur 22 tentatives quelque
chose comme ça donc je 2 sur 14 par an
moins de 4 secondes dans la position
c'est ça non en fin de quart-temps
d'accord ok ok après on sait qu'il faut
que ce chantage de ce moment glas de fin
de cette statistique la sont
traditionnellement plus faibles que des
pourcentages habituels qu'on a bien sûr
joué a par contre fait pas exception
oui on est d'accord et puis que vous
avez de la balle dans les mains dans ces
moments là est forcément plus votre
pourcentage va s'en ressentir puisque
son compte
rarement des tirs faciles voilà ça c'est
le petit point stats par rapport à la
création
moi honnêtement
j'ai été bluffé par ce que c'est pas
vraiment le commencez à me connaître
j'imagine dans le dans le podcast moi
j'aime les gros babar donc les gars ils
font un 80,6 free c'est en 91 qui sont
plutôt dans j'aime pas trop prêter ma
balle et je joue tout seul
j'exagère bien sûr mais c'est c'est pas
trop ma tasse de thé
lui m'a surpris on va on va développer
après mais justement je pense qu'il est
capable de créer pour lui et qui est
capable de créer pour les autres et pour
revenir sur l'histoire de la situation
je pense que pour les scouts nba c'est
vraiment parfait de le voir comme ça
parce que il est obligé de partager
quand la gonfle et il est obligé de
partager les responsabilités quand il
est arrivé en nba c'est sûr que même en
étant dans la plus mauvaise équipe nba
il verra pas tous les tickets shoots
manu on reste sur la création est ce que
pour toi il a les forces nécessaires en
nico nico imagine assez bien loin un
certain potentiel de ce côté en gros
pour créer il faut évidemment le haendel
il faut évidemment savoir créer savoir
créer un décalage aussi soit par ses
feintes soit par sa vitesse ou son
explosivité et puis il faut aussi une
vision de jeu et une habileté technique
que ce soit dans le dribble ou dans la
passe et ce qui l'a tout ce bagage
technique
moi je fais ce que j'aime bien chez lui
dans ces sites qu'il arrive très bien à
créer son espace pour son tir justement
grâce à des grands pas un peu comme
peuvent faire un don de 6 choo où ils
arrivent à écarter les jambes à c'est
assez rendement et du coup ça lui fait
c'est un gros gros point fort là-dessus
et il a un ancien on hésite et chenoui
qui est assez assez l'état sur certains
sur certains longs moments que j'ai en
tête des actions contre o'byrne où il
arrive tout de suite il fait son truc
beau mais le défenseur est complètement
à la ramasse et il arrive tout de suite
à paf il voit tout et c'est souvent
dedans avec lui donc moi je suis assez
d'accord avec nico je le vois bien
réussir au niveau supérieur là dessus a
gardé cette capacité à pouvoir créer à
analyser le
je un peu de son défenseur est arrivé à
à le faire déjouer
même à 1 91 parce qu'il n'est pas
forcément long c'est pas le joueur sait
pas lui faire injure que de dire qu'il
est le joueur qui n'est pas le plus
rapide pardon la n6 guèye le sera un peu
moins encore en nba même s'il reste
explosif je vous pose la question à tous
les trois est ce que vraiment faim
quelques elle est vraiment son avenir
parce qu'on parle d'un score micron
d'accord mais pour pour avoir un avenir
comme celui ci il faut être excellent
dans un domaine au moins si je peux me
permettre pour pour lancer parce que
j'aime bien c'est qu'il est avec le
ballon en main tu vois il est capable de
scorer et 2 passes en même temps action
typique qui l'a souvent une sorte de
deux flotteurs ont battu à il peut
présenter la balle pour faire un
flotteur est justement faire avancer le
big men et passer du courant en passeur
temps qu'il est capable de trouver sur
plusieurs situations
et comme tu le dis c'est pas le mec le
plus athlétique un diabète butler
il peut à peine à peine dunk et on l'a
où on l'a vu donkey et deux fois dans la
saison en transition il en a raté un
juste derrière parce que voilà il est
vraiment ils montent pas au du tout et
donc ça l'obligent justement à
travailler via le haendel et comme on
disait avec l'hésitation de nouveaux cas
peu d'échangés rythme d'accélérer d'un
seul coup et donc ça mais qui peut faire
carrière là-dessus qu'elle est bon fan
de moto qui passe en carrière en plus le
montant vu que c'est pas genre ses
qualités athlétiques qui se repose nigo
pour moi bien sûr bien évidemment il a
il a un avenir en nba dans un profil à
la jordan clarkson où il a une taille
quasiment similaire il est on parle d'un
joueur qui est capable de de jouer c'est
un contre un et de ne pas être ridicule
au contact des gros pour finir ils
utilisent très bien son corps pour pour
se protéger des gros il est capable de
marquer après écran de marquer sur
sortir après écran après dribble sur du
catch and shoot
malgré une mécanique qui est pas
forcément à montrer dans toutes les
écoles de basket
c'est un score et etc
le but du basket alors il ya certes un
coach qui vont vous dire c'est de
prendre un point de moins que
l'adversaire a pu y en a d'autres et
c'est beaucoup le cas en nba qui vont
vous dire si on peut mettre 140 points à
mettre à 140 points donc c'est c'est
vraiment un joueur qui est fait pour
pour ça même s'il n'a pas un premier pas
très explosif
même si pour moi c'est pas un vrai
meneur de par sa création offensive et
de par son scoring
il trouvera un rôle qu'elle quels outils
l'utilisent nico pour aller un peu plus
loin dans le détail manu parlais tout à
l'heure c'est grand appui où il est
capable de deux d'allonger les appuis
justement tout en conservant de la
vitesse de la puissance de l'explosivité
quelques l autre chose d'à pu voir chez
lui je vais pas parler forcément
d'outils techniques mais la chose qui
m'a frappé on en parlait ensemble avant
moi je n'ai vu que quatre matches sur
les quatre matches ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que il adapte sa vitesse de lâcher
de balle selon la situation est en fait
plus il est sous pression et met mieux
et tire et quand il quand il a le temps
ils baissent trop son ballon avant de
après sur la mécanique il ya des choses
à il ya des scories mais mais mais la
réussite est là donc quelque part on
s'en fout est ce que le tir et
projetable en nba
oui parce que justement ce que je te dis
quand il est sous pression il a une
capacité à tirer très vite et pour moi
c'est ça le l'outil principal tu sais le
goût d'esprit qui fait plein plein de
deux d'études sur sur les leviers
moderne sur ce qui change et il
expliquait que le aujourd'hui la plupart
des franchises quand elle recherchait un
sweeter elles vont regarder le
pourcentage oui mais elles vont surtout
regarder la vitesse de relisent et je
pense que malgré sa taille quand on
quand on quand on le voit jouer c'est
son ultime loin c'est sa capacité à
scorer sa capacité à tirer vite à
s'adapter à la défense
et est-ce qu'on va parler du jeu sans
ballon ou est-ce que j'en parle tout de
suite on
à parler du jeu sans ballon je donne
juste quelques stats pour agrémenter ce
que tu viens de dire si tu me permets
69% de réussite au cercle
ça c'est ce que tu avais dit avant c'est
quelqu'un qui encaisse bien le contact
effectivement et au niveau des ses tirs
à trois points
il peut shooter effectivement sous
pression et il peut shooter après
dribble aussi alors il en a pas mis des
mille et des cents en sortie de dribble
mais il en a déjà mis 12 cette saison
des shoots à trois points en sortie de
dribble
donc c'est déjà pas mal et 19 jumper à
deux points aussi où il a un pourcentage
à un peu beaucoup moins même nom ça va
j'ai en train de redécouvrir les stades
mais un pourcentage assez correcte sur
les longs de points ce qui est aussi une
qui peut être un indicateur d'une future
adresse à trois points
hugues juste pour rebondir sur ce que
disait nico concernant la la capacité à
finir au cercle assez bonne la victoire
c'est quand même une conférence assez
physique
donc c'est pas rien de réussir ces
chiffres-là 69% en cercle dans cette
conférence avec cette opposition
oui oui on a une ligue 1 en fin d'année
de conférence assez relevé un beaucoup
d'équipés d'ailleurs qui sont projetés
dans le top 25
avec des t bonds babar athlétique
on a un joueur du coup bon après le
défaut que je trouve c'est qui comme il
n'est pas très athlétique qui montrent
pas très haut il va pas réussir a
provoqué beaucoup de fautes
ça ça me gêne un petit peu il va
beaucoup être pas là dans le petit
périmètre n'est pas provoquée à cette
faute et où il a joué contre des
décombres au profil l'équipe iv qui a eu
à poser le plus de problèmes
basset oklahoma state justement avec une
équipe que délier
sasaki l'homme et il a mis dans le plus
difficile dans le plu en le mal c'est
une équipe avec 5 et sur le terrain
l'équipe de quelques nikam justement le
probable le potentiel promis futur
premier choix de la draft à nico et
vocal jeu sans ballon man hulk est ce
que tu as à dire sur jarrett butler qui
courent utilisent des écrans cook est ce
qu'il est est ce qu'il est déjà armé ce
qu'il est déjà habitué à ne pas trop
avoir le ballon en main ouais parce que
c'est comme disait luxe et pas forcément
lui qui m'ont toujours le ballon mais
c'est plus de viande mitchell et 8 du
coût a vraiment cette habitude d'aller
se démarquer d'aller se place et d'aller
chercher l'écran d'aller chercher les
l'espace suffisant et après c'est lui
qui va du à faire la pâte qui va faire
le show
après il ya quelques défauts des
tendances je trouve être assez attirés
par le ballon en attaque mais qui ne va
pas forcément bouger il va rester à côté
du mineur demander la balle
et voilà donc ça me gêne un peu mais ça
se travaille
assez assez facilement ne jugez pas
d'inquiétude là-dessus le concernant
nico qu'est ce que tu voulais dire toi
sur ce fait dans le sens de manu par
contre il ya des flashes of the ball qui
sont super intéressant d sur le jeu pour
certaines rencontres où il se décide à
lâcher du regard le ballon et à se dire
ah je vais essayer de proposer un cut je
vais je vais essayer de 2 comment dire
de d'enlever de stretch et la défense
évidemment je suis d'accord avec manu
pour l'instant c'est pas assez
mais le fait qu'ils soient capables on
va dire une à deux fois par an contre
c'est peut-être un peu plus encore une
fois que j'exagère mais je grossis le
trait de le faire je trouve que c'est
positif dans le sens où quand il va
arriver à l'échelon supérieur il va
encore moins avoir le ballon en tout cas
au début et il va être obligé pour
exister de de proposer ces choses là
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire
sur le aug ball sinon on va parler
défense bah je rejoins tout ce qui était
dit moi j'aime bien son jeu sans ballon
la spéciale qu'ils aient acquis là c'est
la stephen curry c'est je suis à 45°
j'ai un tir à trois points je passe me
repositionne directement dans le corner
et je suis prêt les mains elle sent
prête donc j'aime bien ça ok ça bouge
après après avoir lâché le ballon
effectivement c'est une arme importante
l'exemple ultime étant effectivement
c'était ça la défense maintenant je
continuais eu il pourra pas exister en
janvier s'il ne défend pas au moins
correctement les bases arrière on va
dire c'est pas une superstar en
puissance biesheim avance peut-être mais
il faudra qui le défendent suffisamment
et ce qui me l'a les armes qu est ce qu
il a montré sur ce côté je pense qu'on
va pour les efforts on va se séparer en
deux parties aura la défense anne boleyn
la défense aux bolton
un profil qui a s'est opposé près du
chemin sur le ballon moi j'aime bien
parce qu'il est assez puissant il peut
quand même tenir le jeu le porteur de
balle en face de lui il ya peu défaut là
dessus vous il a une tendance à vouloir
jp la balle dans les mains donc il tente
beaucoup d'interceptions là tu feras
parti fasse attention aussi il n'ya pas
pour pas trop se faire passer c'est
quelqu'un qui comprend quand même plutôt
bien le
je pense qu'il aura un impact positif
défensivement sur les porteurs de balle
en nba il aurait il pourra tenir des
profils un peu plus grands un peu plus
puissant que lui
et puis je pense que je vais laisser la
parole à mai à mes camarades du coup
pour la défense est loin du ballon c'est
peut être une autre paire de manches
convard et on va on va sortir les guns
la ferme pour manu gérer les premiers
messieurs les normands les normands elia
suleiman la nakba c'est ce que je disais
plus plus ou moins au niveau de la taxe
il est attiré par le ballon
donc du coup il a vraiment tendance des
fois oublié son défenseur mais vraiment
oublier complètement lui il tournait le
dos vraiment être attiré par le ballon
et le quasiment là la prise à bail un
instantané mais c'est là aussi qu'il est
forte parce que il sur la défense comme
ça il est vraiment super intéressant
parce qu'il a le quasiment les bons
gestes tout le temps mais moi juste que
j'attends sur lui c'est vraiment qu'il
soit un peu plus concentré sur son
joueur
justement parce que je s'il est à 100 %
sur son joueur il peut vraiment devenir
une arme défensive vraiment intéressante
même en nba et ouais pouvoir des fonds
du coup pouvoir défendre sur sur
plusieurs postes après lâcher un peu
plus j'attends de voir parce que pour
moi ça sa taille et ne gêne un peu mais
est ce qu'il va être capable de défendre
jusqu'à déchu sur des ailiers celle à
qui va-t-on qu'il va être intéressant de
voir sa position
oui c'est ce que j'allais dire c'est
étonnant le portrait de vous dresser de
la défense sur le porteur parce que
parce qu'il est donc maintenant je vais
vous explosif a parlé avec sur pardon
jeudi à tanger pas encore donné mon avis
à whitehorse
mais j'allais donner la parole juste
avant j'allais dire est ce que tu peux
me veux-tu nuancer ce propos mais tu
peux continuer ta phrase je voulais
justement savoir si j'avais à l'aise
dans ton sens ou pas et bien qu est ce
que tu voulais reprocher bah je ne
voulais rien reprocher je constate juste
que
on le décrit j'ai vu un joueur pas très
explosif très grand pas très long donc
pourquoi serait-il un atout défensif au
niveau supérieur
alors je vais répondre à ta question
mais avant ça je suis d'accord avec toi
sur sur la taille sur sur le comment
dire l'aspect c'est pas un joueur qui va
pouvoir switcher pour moi sur pick'n
roll par exemple et donc c'est plutôt
emmerdant quand on peut pas défendre sur
plusieurs postes
après lucas un avis différent il avait
plus de match je respectais pas de
soucis sur les quatre que j'ai vu moi
j'ai constaté un niveau de concentration
très aléatoire alors on peut dire oui il
est jeune il ya plein de jeunes qui
réussissent est constant défensivement
plus que lui il est effectivement très
attiré par le ballon mais du coup ça va
même parfois jusqu'à des situations un
peu ridicule où on parlait en off sur la
première mi-temps d'auburn
il ya deux plaies où il est il est déjà
dans la raquette avant qu'il ya un drive
à l'opposé il perd son joueur de vue il
ne le trouve pas il s'en fout il
continue il reste est du coup on a un
joueur qui a créé tout seul à trois
points sur le sur le secteur 0 ça c'est
quand même plutôt embêtant du coup voilà
au niveau des efforts sur les écrans il
est fait pas toujours
maintenant ce qui est essentiel propos
sont vendus et pour tous les modes graft
pour la projection en nba c'est que pour
contenir les drive pour cela idées
franchement est excellent et il est il
et il est capable de rester entre le
ballon et le panier jusqu'au bout en
utilisant très intelligemment son corps
donc ça c'est son atout principal
en défense on l'aurait jupe l'uic est ce
qu'ils bénéficient pas là-dessus delà de
la défense collective d'auburn qui quand
même fourni en joueurs athlétiques et
donc qu'ils peuvent aussi intimidé loin
du ballon et et restreindre même quand
ils défendent pas directement sur le
porteur le périmètre du porteur de balle
est donc
l'attaquant qui fait ça cette jarre est
bouclé merci je pense que tu as raison
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il est temps
porté sur l'aide je pense qu il quelque
part ils comptent peut-être un peu trop
sur ses coéquipiers pour pour faire le
commandant le sale boulot
alors voilà il ya toujours une histoire
est ce que c'est le contexte est ce que
c'est l'instinct ou est ce que c'est
vraiment un joueur un peu feignant
on va passer justement sur l'attitude
qui est très importante qui est
primordial une au niveau de l'attitude
qu'est ce que tu as vu qu est ce que tu
as pu relever
toi qui a vu beaucoup de matchs de
baylor c'est un joueur qui s'est pas le
plus expressif de son équipe moi j'en
parlais tout à l'heure il ya un certain
pivot qui s'appelle tous n'attendent
chamois de choix qui est la plus grosse
pom-pom girls de la delà de la première
division bon voilà c'est sont un peu
opposés à ces fermes et maintenance à un
genre qui très collectif le qui aime
bien quand ses coéquipiers brille sur le
terrain et en interview il est fini
c'est beaucoup il les ensembles beaucoup
c'est quelqu'un qui se laisse pas
démonter ses tirades quelque chose
j'aime bien il va prendre le prochain
tir il sait qu'il peut le mettre donc il
le prendra voilà c'est un c'est un
joueur je pense qu'il ya une bonne
confiance en lion dans ton interview et
ça se ressent aussi sur le terrain manu
qui a vu qu'elle dure plus ou moins la
même chose moi c'est son comportement
bas surtout sur le terrain de chant me
choque pas plus que ça donc avoir la
presse sur les joueurs comme ça qui sont
ancrées dans un programme est ancré dans
un collectif ce qui va compter c'est
plus les intel puisque les îles et dans
un cocon il sait comment agir et la
confiance de son coach et que c'était et
c'est donc là ce qui compte pour moi
selon moi c'est vraiment les intel comme
mollet à l'entraînement comment il est
dans la vie de tous les jours en fait
c'est vraiment là qu'on va pouvoir juger
véritablement son son comportement est
ce qu'il a dans la tête attendait intel
qu à écoute je n'ai pas eu forcément le
temps de beaucoup creuser le seul chose
que j'ai reçu c'est dérisoire red flag
donc du coup on peut dire que c'est
positif 8 allait prendre la parole
alors en fait il là il s'est présenté
pour participer un comité qui représente
les étudiants athlètes basketteurs
auprès de l'acier en fait et donc lille
en a il a été pris il a été sélectionné
donc c'est un des deux seuls bavasser
fait partie donc des deux basketteurs
universitaire qui représente les
étudiants basketteur au niveau de
l'aisne ciller avec beaucoup de
directeur athlétique de mecs justement
de la ligue et tout ça est donc lui
disais que c'était important justement
de représenter les droits des étudiants
et qui voyait aussi possiblement une
opportunité pour une suite de carrière
pour travailler après après sa carrière
pro de basket heures dans une fac en
tant que directeur athlétique où ces
choses là
donc voilà il a il a un projet sur le
long terme et il participe à la vie de
étudiante et à la vie sportif heures en
dehors du moment où il est sur le
terrain quoi très intéressant très
intéressant ce que tu racontes
c'est je sais je sais y non mais c'est
voilà c'est le genre de chose qui peut
donner de la matière un esprit aussi
derrière un joueur aller plus loin que
simplement regarder les matchs et des
vidéos non voilà c'est très intéressant
tu sais qui est l'autre joueur aubin
alors non je n'ai pas noté le nom il ya
l'interview est disponible un jour sur
youtube on la trouve assez rapidement
mais je crois que c'est un joueur qui
joue à howard mais je suis pas sûr ok
moi qui pensais qu'on avait pris hugues
juste pour ça vaut à à la nick kay je
suis déçu il n'arrivait pas uniquement
là pour faire pour avoir une belle voix
il a en plus d infos bravo encore
faut-il chercher je vais on va terminer
ce podcast simplement avec sa projection
puisque je l'avais prévu dans le menu
mais notre ami denzel sur twitter @
denzel house nous a posé la question vu
la saison que fait baylor est ce que
vous imaginez vraiment qu'ils puissent
prix mieux qu'une fin de 1er tour
messieurs je vais commencer par man
ouais moi pour l'instant la saison gelé
sur une possible draft je lai entre 15
et 20 ah c'est pas du big bang je parle
vraiment d'une possible au noir
ouais ouais donc à arras et au quand
même relativement aux oies se remet à la
sortie ça manque draft ouvrière
aujourd'hui on enregistre le mardi je
précise il me semble qu'ils avaient en
fin de premier tour entre 20 et 30 à
hull oui je l'a peu près je l'a peu près
dans le même ring c'est le moment je
commence à regarder
peut-être des joueurs d'expérience
puisque des talents vers ce moment là et
donc que c'est un des premiers qui me
vient devant les jets pas de qui on
pourrait citer david du ou des choses
comme ça qui peuvent re qui peuvent
tourner c'est le premier team dire parmi
les juniors nigaud pareil on en parlait
ensemble et je trouve que c'est pour moi
c'est très difficile de le situer parce
que djawad bateleur il sera pris
uniquement par une équipe qui a besoin
d'un scoreur au post arrière en sortie
de banc pour on y croit oui donc du coup
battu diddz déjà les clippers bon ils
ont passé mauvais mauvais exemple ils
ont ils n'ont pas de pics jusqu'à en
2048 mais ça sera forcément une équipe
qui va le draft et par besoin
en tout cas c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça que je dois peut-être que je me
trompe mais du coup il a fallu que je le
situe je l'aimais fin de premier tour
mais pour moi mais en sachant qu'il
pourrait être
il pourrait être drafté en 15 que ça ne
choquera pas parce que dans le rôle
qu'on va lui donner
ce sera quelqu'un qui est qui répondra
aux attentes
bien sûr ce sera quelqu'un qui sera visé
pour un rôle spécifique
quoi donc donc on peut peut-être exclure
la loterie quoique on a vu des équipes
faire ce genre de choix en 35 de loterie
souvent mais mais effectivement là on se
rappelle de tout c'est le volant oui
effectivement que tu es fans des bulls
pour contexte je triche un peu j'ai pas
les meilleures anecdotes washington et
ça a été moins bonne carrière en nba par
contre un peu moins
contrairement à pic et washington qui
nous régale on l'adorait dans le contest
on va le répéter aussi souvent que l'on
peut voit là messieurs on a fait le sale
tour peut-être pas prétentieux mais en
tout cas on a dressé le portrait de
jarret de belles fleurs merci beaucoup
c'était rapide et complète
c'était un peu de buts et merci à vous
trois est ce que vous avez un mot de fin
a peut-être un chouchou autre joueur à
surveiller du côté de baylor on en a
déjà cité mais est ce que en regardant
baylor vous avez repéré un autre joueur
que vous aimez beaucoup que l'on va pas
vous demander de pronostics de draft
mais que vous aimez beaucoup on va avoir
le même
hugues et moi oui moi aussi je n'attends
chamois tout cas tu vois comme comme on
veut et gwyneth jones choix oui david et
johnny depp donc l'intérieur sauf amorcé
sa red shirt watchers ce format il vient
du grenelle viie la catch up pour passer
un an développer son corps et il a pris
20 kilos de muscles très bien et hulene
sens que tu as fait un infiltrait de
twitter sur ce joueur sur wii il
exactement
donc on peut le retrouver sur ton compte
twitter danois le @ parce que je me
trompais alors dur g uerre comment je
t'appelle ça est caillassé à auch à y
voilà vous n'aurez pas l'excusé de ne
pas connaître l'intérieur red shirt
sophomore de baylor dont je ne me
risquerai pas à prononcer le nom manu un
joueur de moins alors moi c'est un petit
duo matthew myers et des viandes
mitchell que j'ai alors david mitchell
effectivement on l'a vu sur des noirs
graft c'est le meneur dont on a parlé
d'un scout casse et l'autre qui est
matthew maynard pour les tiens un junior
aussi un ailier qui shoote beaucoup mais
moi j'aime bien quand ça shoote beaucoup
effectivement c'est le justin bieber
croqueur de deux plus grandes new york
un style mais à venir dans en nba mais
j'aime bien ce que ce que je vois ça
vient a retenu les noms et on espère les
voir quelque part peut-être peut-être en
europe peut-être pris en chasse à l'élan
de chalon dédicace à ben messieurs merci
une nouvelle fois et à ceux qui nous
écoutent merci encore plus merci encore
encore plus pour tous les retours qu'on
a eues par rapport à l'épisode précédent
concernant le le recrutement des joueurs
et comment évaluer sa lancée
c'était très gratifiant pour nous
d'avoir vous faire en retour donc merci
à vous puis on se retrouve très bientôt
pour un épisode 10 déjà de cette saison
quatre là c'était l'épisode 9 et en
attendant vous pouvez aller consulter
notre site envergure en ces mots il ya
déjà d'ailleurs scouting n'importe qui
date de l'année dernière sur leur site
écrit par alan alan qui a aussi sorti un
article concernant jawad grimont ça va
être la sensation avec kunhinga de la
g-league cette année il est attendu dans
le top 5 de la drassm qu'aller voir le
scouting report concernant enfin un
article concernant ses performances en
au lycée et en compétitions fiba
messieurs à bientôt
et à ceux qui nous écoutent à très
bientôt chalon